what
um what is the like expectation now
moving forward is this is are you guys
gonna make her doing the dude scene a
regular thing we're definitely gonna do
more of it but I would say like the
frequency is probably the thing that's
kind of Up For Debate that we're still
kind of figuring out and like you know
there's some stuff that I really don't
mind at all like like I probably would
have been real nervous about it before
but like me [__] her with another guy
I don't really like feel any type of way
about that anymore like that's no
problem like I'll definitely do that
would you do the would you do the DP
yeah I feel like that's on the bucket
list but then that's like a dick on dick
yeah and you know it's like I'm not
gonna [__] a dude Kev listen I don't
want you to [__] do but if you're
gonna do the DP there's no way that your
guys's dicks don't touch or ball slap or
just you're crossing swords I gotta do
it one time before I die okay and you
might I mean you got to do I mean
obviously you're married so it's got to
be with you my leg bumps another dude's
leg it's like whatever we all been in
the gym locker room before or whatever
but also like I don't know like it's got
to be a homie I think it's got to be
something I'm like real cool with would
you ever do anything with a transporn
star no
even if it was like [__] your wife
with a trans porn star
I don't feel like I want to turn our sex
life into a culture War thing you know
if I just
I'm not trying to like prove my wokeness
or anything and I [__] with a lot of
trans uh women and stuff like have had a
lot of them on the podcast I had mro's
on the podcast I think I saw a little
bit of the uh you guys did like a um a
panel right it was like yeah yeah yeah
and I got to meet a lot of really cool
trans people in that situation and
everything but my whole thing is like
I'm not really trying to do anything on
camera for money that I wouldn't want
really in my private life as well yeah
so like I don't you know and even like
I'll like I'm not personally really like
Mega attracted to a BBW that's like 400
pounds right would I maybe do it on
camera like maybe yeah like that doesn't
would you pop a blue shoe
I might have to pop something I don't
know yeah my papa energy drink my papa's
C4 let's not give them any free [__]
publicity there all right that's why I
have their logo turned away from them
this guy's over here got the Celsius on
the floor
man we're over here drinking [__]
Energy Drinks like a couple of real
white guys like a couple of real Arizona
and New Hampshire white boys right
oh [__] now you know the one thing I
would say is like
I I've you know I have for whatever
reason I think people think we're like a
lot like we're cool like I think me and
you are cool I think we're friends you
know like but
I have so many people in my life that
came to me like I'm like your
representative and they're like yo son
what's up with your boy and I'm like at
the end of the day
this guy's a professional porn star
who's [__] however many hundreds of
women since he's been in his
relationship to me
it's not that big of a deal right
that she gets one
yeah I mean it is weird because it's
like yeah I have [__] all these chicks
with her and nobody really like ever
made a big deal about it like you know
and it's a double standard thing and
it's also kind of because we're like
we're in hip-hop culture and it I think
that's where it kind of like people are
like yo like bro like yeah and I
expected like hip-hop to have strong
opinions about it but I didn't really
expect there to be like 20 bar stool
articles and you know to have like
Andrew Tate Logan Paul all these people
like discussing it in depth on their
podcast and [__] you know I didn't
expect to have everyone in the whole
world having conversations about it
which that surprised me there was I I
want to say I saw an old interview clip
it might have been when you were on
flagrant where you had pretty much I
could be you know you're right yeah I
shut the door on it you pretty much shut
the door hard on like what changed which
is weird because maybe a year before
that I remember I went on academics's
podcast and he asked if I would ever do
a threesome with another dude and my
girl and I basically like left the door
open for it and was just kind of like
you know yeah I would be open to it like
I would be interested in it I didn't say
that I was gonna do it but I said I'd be
open to the idea and I remember even at
that time just me suggesting that I
would maybe be down for it was so viral
and such a big thing and academics
freaked out and could not believe that I
was acknowledging it and even on Vlad
there was a clip I saw like because I I
talked on interviews so much that I
forget what I say and but I'm glad I
said the same thing I said like
I would consider it you know and so yeah
like the clipping went viral though was
me saying that I definitely wouldn't do
it which is pretty funny but uh yeah I
mean what changed is basically just me
getting a little bit more open-minded as
time went by and like you know me and
her talked about like swinging off
camera and like hooking up with like a
different couple together or something
like that take a Friday night go out on
the town get a hotel room something like
that maybe but then we were like well if
we're ever gonna do that like we
probably should film it and if we're
gonna we should make some money yeah you
should probably like make your first
scene with another guy like a big
blowout thing pause